The first solution is acceptable, for the most part. It solves the problem of
two surfaces being in the same location. However, it does change the geometry
of the model, which might not be acceptable. also, even surfaces that are near
each other can still have Z-fighting problems, since the Z buffer has limits on
its precision. So, this solution works, but it's not optimal. The second
solution sounds nice. A new graphics card is always fun, but it doesn't help at
all. Since both surfaces are in an identical location, which one happens to be
closer is entirely arbitrary. Another GPU can and will give you a different
view of Z-fighting. So if you like the Z-fighting effect, you can control it if
your users are on different machines with different GPUs. The third answer is
switching to another is switching to another rendering algorithm, again, will
just cause different precision errors to show up. The underlying problem of two
surfaces being in the same place is a modeling error and can't be solved by
rendering. The forth answer, removing the bottom part of the leg that overlaps
with the foot, is certainly the cleanest solution. This is also the most
efficient answer, as making the object smaller will mean it covers less pixels
and so causes less work.